this morning we continue our reporting
on thousands of migrants most of them
from haiti making their way through a
dangerous stretch of latin america right
now more than 90 thousand people have
crossed from colombia to panama this
year an unprecedented number yesterday
manuel bajorkas introduced us to lionel
nelson a haitian migrant trying to get
to the u.s with his wife and baby girl
manuel followed them as they tried to
make their way from columbia to panama
and handed themselves over to smugglers
it's been a rough road for lionel nelson
and his family
but the most treacherous part of their
journey had yet to begin
as they left the columbian beach town of
nekokli by ferry
we followed along by boat to the other
side of this bay the next step in the
trek north for all the people on that
boat this is the only way to the other
side a two-hour journey across the bay
to akandee
so the boats just arrived on the other
side and as we came into the bay it's
met by smaller boats
and these are all part of the smuggling
operation taking them from this boat
to dry land
this would be the last time we saw any
colombian government forces or officials
nelson and his family turned themselves
over to a band of smugglers after
negotiating passage along the only land
route into central america
we followed nelson and his family on
dirt bikes out into the countryside and
up into the hills
your girl how is she
okay
she looks a little
scared a little bit
see
we rode for more than an hour struggling
through mud and streams to where the
hills become mountains at a smuggler's
camp on the edge of the jungle
this camp is the place where many of
these migrants spend one night before
they go on into the darien gap those who
run this camp here who are very weary of
our cameras but this is it from here on
out it's all by foot
and it's all through the jungle
to understand how treacherous the
terrain is consider this
the pan-american highway or via
panamericana runs from alaska all the
way to argentina but the road stops
between the borders of panama and
columbia a 66-mile stretch of untamed
wilderness too difficult to build that's
why it's called the darian gap
despite the dangers the number of
migrants braving the gap has skyrocketed
more than 90 thousand people are
estimated to have passed through this
year
have you seen these numbers ever in your
life
this smuggler who would not give his
name told as his people only take the
migrants as far as the border with
panama then leave them in god's hands
they'd rather
die trying to get to the united states
than be deported to haiti
and it is into that jungle of rivers
rocks wild animals and criminals that
nelson and his family are headed the
plan was to leave first thing in the
morning
nelson says he's prepared for the
roughly three day journey through the
wilderness a journey he knows is full of
danger
it's all hearts
we've yet to hear whether they made it
out of the jungle for cbs mornings
manuel bojorquez nicko clay colombia
[Music]
wow
the images are heartbreaking and when
you think the treacherous conditions
that you go through to risk yourself but
more importantly to risk the lives of
your children that's how desperate you
are you're not putting your kids in that
water unless you think it's safer and
better than where you're coming from
yeah well done by manuel but with that
said the the journey is so treacherous
what did the one smugglers say we put
them in god's hands we get them to that
line and then they're in god's hands and
we pray for their protection yes we do